[Music]
hello
i'm alexander rose the executive
director here at long now
i'm here at the interval in san
francisco where i'll be joined remotely
by our speaker today wade davis this is
the second talk that wade davis has
given in our series the first one was on
indigenous technologies and how that's
useful in the modern world
and today he's going to be talking about
the field of anthropology and where
it's come from where it's going and
really maybe how it can help the world
that we're living in today
welcome wade davis well thanks for
alexander and thanks to the long now
foundation it's wonderful
work you do and it's great to be back
part of a
part of your family and i'd like to
share a story with you today that may
seem like a small
matter a kind of a a tempest and an
academic teapot if you will but it's one
with
significant ramifications if we are ever
to truly live
in a kind of pluralistic multicultural
world
now ruth benedict the acolyte of the
great franz boaz
and in 1947 the president of the
american anthropological association
reputedly said that the very purpose
of anthropology was to make the world
safe
for human differences in the immediate
wake of 9 11 and i was living in
washington dc at the time
the american anthropological association
actually met
in the nation's capital 4 000
anthropologists were in washington in
the wake of the biggest story of culture
they or the entire country would ever
face
the entire gathering earned but a
mention
in the washington post newspaper in the
gossip section in the style section a
few lines
that essentially reported that the nut
cases were back in town
and it was hard to know who was more
remiss
the government for failing to listen to
the one
profession that could have answered the
question then on the lips
of all americans why do they hate us
or the profession itself for failing to
reach beyond itself to bring its
considerable insights and wisdom to the
attention
of the nation perhaps
fittingly it took an outsider to remind
anthropologists
why anthropology matters charles king
a professor of international affairs at
georgetown university
begins this remarkable book of his by
asking us a very
to kind of participate in a very simple
thought experiment
to just envision the world as it was
in the lives of our grandparents perhaps
your
great-grandparents now think for a
moment about
how it was in edwardian england or
america at the time before the
first world war race
charles notes was accepted as a given a
biological fact
with lineages dividing white from black
that reached back through
primordial time differences in customs
and
beliefs reflected differences in
intelligence
and destiny with every culture finding
its place on a
on a rung of an evolutionary ladder that
went from the savage to the barbarian
to the civilized of the strand of london
with technological wizardry
the great achievement of the west being
the sole measure
of progress and success sexual
and behavioral characteristics were
fixed
whites were smart and industrious and
some people
were barely people at all incredibly as
recently as 1902 in the lifetime
of my grandfather it was debated in
melbourne australia
as to whether or not the aboriginal
peoples of australia
were in fact human or not women's
suffrage only came in 1919
three years after the birth of my father
immigrants in almost all nations were
seen as a threat
even by those who had only recently
themselves
clawed their way ashore the poor
of course were responsible for their own
miseries
as for the blind the deaf the dumb the
cripples and the mad
they were best locked away lobotomized
or even killed to remove them from the
gene pool
in the time of my grandfather the
superiority of the white male
was accepted with such assurance that
the concise oxford english dictionary
published in 1911
had no entries for racism or colonialism
interracial marriage remained illegal
in much of the united states until 1967.
now here we are two generations
later and it goes without saying that no
educated person would share any of these
bankrupt certitudes that i've now listed
all of which raises a question
what was it that allowed our culture
to go from zero to 60 in a generation
now all of those were political
movements but political movements are
built
fundamentally on the possibility of
change
and the catalyst as charles king reminds
us
in his wonderful book was the wisdom
and scientific genius of franz
boaz and a small band of courageous
scholars
margaret mead alfred krober elsie
cluells parsons
melva herskovitz edward sapir
robert lowry ruth benedict the
incomparable
zord neil hurston and many others
contrarians
all who came into his orbit
destined to change the world
and we today live in the social
landscape
of their dreams the scientific
realization that humanity
is one interconnected and undivided
whole now widely acknowledged
as a father of american cultural
anthropology
franz boaz was the first scholar to
explore
in a truly open and neutral manner
how human social perceptions are formed
and how members of distinct societies
become
conditioned to see and interpret the
world
far far ahead of his times doing his
field work
in the 1880s boaz recognized
that every distinct social community was
a unique
facet of the human legacy and its
promise
each was a product of its own history
none existed in some absolute
sense we create our social realms
boaz would say determine what we then
define
as being common sense universal truths
the appropriate rules and codes of
behavior
beauty really does lie in the eye of the
beholder
manners don't make the man men and women
invent the manners race
and gender are cultural constructs
derived not from biology but born
in the realm of ideas now critically
none of this implied an extreme
relativism
as if every human behavior had to be
accepted simply because it exists boaz
never
called for the elimination of judgment
only its suspension
so the very judgments that were obliged
to make ethically and morally
as human beings may be informed ones
now boaz has come in for a lot of
criticism in the kind of
revisionist era of anthropology and he
was by no means a perfect man
as wendy wickwire's brilliant recent
book on james tate suggests
boaz could be petty vainglorious
fiercely ambitious insecure
unacknowledged
jealous covetous slow to share credit
both threatened by and resentful of
anyone else's success
but all of that said in 1883
he lived on baffin island for two
12-month periods a participant observer
in the fullest sense
completely depended on his inuit
companions
eating what they ate wearing what they
wore
and traveling as they traveled by dog
sled
and small boat in 1898
he was one of the first to speak out
against the potlatch ban
in the pacific northwest he spoke out
from the earliest days
against the residential schools just as
he spoke out in favor
of the rights of the native american
church to use peyote
in its sacred ceremonies in 1911
when again to remind you the oxford
english dictionary did not even have an
entry for racism boaz wrote
there is no fundamental difference in
the ways of thinking
of so-called primitive and civilized man
a connection between race and
personality has never been established
the concept of racial type as commonly
used in the scientific literature
is misleading and wrong achievements
of races do not warrant us to assume
that one race can possibly be
more gifted than another as a mentor
and a teacher he supported zora neale
hurston
a black woman in the 1920s who got her
phd by studying the richness of black
folkloric culture in the american south
his support for ella deloria
a dakota woman was equally strong and
exceptional
as for colonialism and the treatment of
native people
he wrote in 1919 any policy that
increases production of valuable raw
products by exploitation of the country
that destroys the social life of the
natives
must be condemned it is obvious
that fair and decent policies will never
be introduced so long as
colonies and their inhabitants are
considered
property of colonial powers that exploit
the land
and utilize their inhabitants only for
their own economic purposes
and for fighting their battles now this
at a time
when teddy roosevelt revered today in
the american conservation movement
was dismissing native americans as quote
a pestilence to be removed from the body
of america
inspired by his time amongst the inuit
on baffin island and his
later work amongst the quakawak in the
salmon forest of the pacific northwest
he informed all who would listen that
the other peoples of the world
were not failed attempts to be them
failed attempts to be modern
now here's the amazing part franz boaz
would not live to see his insights and
intuitions
confirmed by hard science let alone
define the zeitgeist
of a new global culture in many ways his
intuition about cultural relativism was
just a poetic flourish a thought a hope
a dream
a prayer for the well-being of humanity
but today
80 years on and long after his death
studies of the human genome have indeed
revealed
that the genetic endowment of humanity
is a continuum
race has been exposed as an utter
fiction but here is the really
extraordinary idea and this is what
he understood in his heart and his soul
and in his mind
if we are all cut from the same fabric
of life
then by definition all peoples all
cultures share the same
mental acuity the same raw genius
and whether that intellectual potential
is exercised through technological
innovation as has been the great
achievement of the west
or through the untangling of the complex
threads of memory
inherent in a myth is simply
a matter of choice and orientation
adaptive insights and cultural emphasis
there is no hierarchy of progress
in the history of culture no
evolutionary
ladder to success boaz and his students
were right the brilliance of scientific
research
the revelations of modern genetics has
affirmed an astonishing way
both the unity of humanity and the
essential wisdom
of cultural relativism every culture
really does have something to say each
deserves to be heard just as none
as a monopoly on the root to the divine
but what does this actually mean for us
how how can we see this
become expressed in studies of culture
well let's slip now into the culture
sphere that is most
antithetical to that of the west we find
ourselves in the great civilization of
australia
we know from studies of the y chromosome
that the ancestors of the australian
aborigines were the very first human
people to walk out
of africa and in 10 000 years they
established 10 000 clan territories
all linked by a single idea and that is
a dreaming
the song lines now the dreaming wasn't a
dream
it was the idea the earth both exists
and is waiting to be formed now when the
british washed ashore
on that distant cotton in the late 18th
century they met a people that looked
strange
who had a simple material technology but
what really offended the british
was that nowhere where they went in no
tribal society of australia did they
ever encounter anybody who had any
interest whatsoever in improving upon
their material lot
the british took great offense and in
their inimicable way decided that the
aboriginal people weren't people at all
and indeed they began to shoot them and
as i said earlier in 1902 it was debated
in parliament as to whether or not
aboriginal people were human in the
1950s
ranchers in australia had had a quotas
of as to how many abos could be shot who
trespassed upon their lands as recently
as 1960s when i was a school boy
a book used in schools across australia
a treasury of fauna of australia
included the aborigines amongst the
interesting forms of wildlife in the
continent
what was actually going on was a
devotional philosophy too subtle for the
british to understand and that was
dreaming and the whole point of the
dreaming was the antithesis of progress
it was stasis it was constancy the
entire idea was to
not change anything but rather to do the
ritual jesters
along the song line which is a
trajectory walked at the dawn of time
by the ancestral beings who sang the
universe into existence
and to do the ritual gestures deemed to
be necessary to keep the world
exactly as it was at the time of its
creation and now the
issue is not to say who's right and
who's wrong had humanity as a whole
followed that
intellectual devotion we wouldn't have
put a man on the moon
but on the other hand we wouldn't be
talking about global climate change
and our capacity to transform the bio
physical
uh and biological support systems of the
entire planet
so this is what the anthropological lens
can can show us let's slip for a moment
into the greatest culture sphere ever
brought into being by the human
imagination
and that of course is polynesia tens of
thousands of islands flung upon
the southern seas 10 centuries before
christ
long before european transports had the
nerve to
sail away from the shores of continents
the ancestors of the polynesian set sail
to the rising sun
and just using celestial navigation
the signs and symbols and messages of
nature
they settle the greatest culture sphere
on the planet
such that you could say today that every
uh thing of the human genius that
allowed
us to put a man on the moon if you
applied that to the oceans
what you would get is polynesia and how
about our relationship
to the planet itself you know climate
change has become humanity's problem
it wasn't caused by humanity it was
caused by a narrow
subset of humanity that for 300 years
has been consuming the ancient
sunlight of the world you know all
cultures
are myopic faithful to their own
interpretation of reality
and we too are products of our own
history
and culture when in the renaissance and
into the enlightenment
we try desperately to liberate ourselves
from the tyranny of absolute faith
when descartes famously said that all
that existed
is mind and material with a single
gesture he deanimated the world and
flung out all notions of myth magic
mysticism and metaphor
to the extent that saul bella would
write science made a house cleaning
of belief and the earth began to be seen
as just a stage set upon which only the
human drama
unfolded we developed a kind of an
extractive model
whereby if the flight of a bird had no
meaning a mountain was mere material and
rock
ready to be mined most peoples around
the world
have established relationships with the
natural world based not on extractive
principles
but on reciprocity some kind of
iteration of the fundamental idea that
the earth owes its bounty to people
people in turn owe their fidelity to the
earth
and that simple equation elaborated
through ritual
and belief has a profound consequence in
terms of the ecological footprint of a
people
i like many of you was raised to believe
that a mountain
existed of rock ready to be mined that a
forest was cellulose
ready to be cut the point is it's not
whether a mountain is rock or as a
spirit it's how the metaphor
plays out in the relationship between
human beings and the natural world
most societies around the world see the
earth
as alive they see it as a force to be
engaged and and filtered through the
human imagination and all of this was
made
possible because boaz and his cadre came
along
to shatter the conventions of european
conceit
it was a shattering of the european mind
the sociological equivalent
of splitting the atom and though
remembered today at least by those of us
who revere them
as the giants of the discipline boaz
and his students margaret mead ruth
benedict all of them
zora neale hurston were in their time
dismissed from jobs because of their
activism
denied promotion because of their
beliefs harassed by the fbi
as the subversives they truly were and
attacked in the press
simply for being different and yet
they stood their ground he would never
sit back in silence as fully half
the languages of the world hover on the
brink of extinction
implying the loss in a single generation
of fully half
of humanity's social ecological and
spiritual knowledge
to those who suggest that indigenous
people are destined to fade away he
would
reply that change in technology is no
threat to culture
but power is cultures under threat are
neither fragile
nor vestigial in every instance they are
living dynamic peoples being driven
out of existence by identifiable forces
that for him was an optimistic
observation because if
human beings are the agents of cultural
destruction
we can be and must be the facilitators
of cultural survival
so anthropology matters as it always has
because it allows us to look under the
surface of things
the very existence of other ways of
being other ways of thinking
other visions of life itself puts a lie
to those of us in our own culture who
say for example that we cannot change
as we surely know we must the
fundamental way in which we inhabit
this planet and as the events of the
last
years have shown the struggle long ago
championed by franz boaz
is lamentably ongoing
never never has a voice of anthropology
being more important but it must be
spoken
to be heard so why isn't it being heard
or i deliberately moved away from the
academic life
in 1986 soon after receiving my own
phd and only returned to the academic
fold
when offered quite unexpectedly a
university
tenured professorship in 2013
when i was 59 years old and i don't know
what happened
but all i can report is that in that
time
anthropology turned inward largely
abandoning its roots and activism
after three decades of what i can only
call
flagellation and almost nihilistic
self-absorption
an outsider could be forgiven for
thinking that contemporary
anthropologists
mostly study themselves
now certainly in the beginning as all
disciplines do
there was reasons for critiques reasons
to
rethink the history and plenty to
criticize
in the history of anthropology hovering
of course over british and french social
anthropology in particular
was always the shadows of a colonial
past you know men
in pith helmets literally dispatched to
understand and interpret the ways of
people that had come
under the rule of colonial authorities
and of course there was also in many of
these
classic situations of a foreign scholar
and a local people
a kind of power dynamic that could be
manipulated and i can only say that if
someone turned up at my house here on
this small island british columbia
and announced that i was going to house
and feed them for
a year and they're here to study my
private life
i call the police and so perhaps it was
inevitable
that as in the way of scholarship a new
generation of scholars would come to
question the certitudes of a previous
generation but it seems to me that
in anthropology it became too much
things got out of hand the baby was
tossed out with a bathwater
legitimate concerns and critiques
tumbled one upon the other
until the very rationale of the
discipline was being called
into question cannibalized by
revisionist contempt
for its elders reduced to the
intellectual equivalent
of the circular firing squad
my experience in anthropology as a
storyteller
traveling the world was very different
when i applied to the nsf
for grants to study the secret societies
at the time
notorious in the literature i received
the money but it was annotated on my
academic grant application
that if i tried to do this work i would
be killed i never felt for a moment
that was the case but the point is even
if it had been the case
it wouldn't have made a difference
because the mission was more important
at that time than any particular
challenges faced by the
individual scholar so for me
anthropology
has always been about activism here is a
world where people die
for years working with the penang to
help protect the force of sarawak
in the face of the greatest and most
intense industrial deforestation
ever to occur in the world and bruno
manser our dear friend and comrade
murdered by the chinese loggers and yet
ian mckenzie
my close friend with whom i wrote a book
a linguist who's devoted himself to that
people that language
and every year since 1993 has returned
to spend six months in the forest to
chronicle
that tongue that language that wisdom
that tradition or my friend alberto
villafana
a leader of the arawaka was murdered by
the paracos
in colombia yet today his son is the
leader
of the arawaka nation tibetan scholar i
traveled 6 000 kilometers width from
chengdu to
lhasa and only when we reached the
ancient tibetan capital
did i learn the story of his family his
father murdered by the red guard
when the maoist took over lhasa in 1959
his uncle escorted
his holiness to freedom in nepal
his mother imprisoned for the sin of
being wealthy
he as a little boy smuggled into the
prison where he spent months beneath her
dress hidden away because she needed to
be with him
and the sister who did that brave deed
put into a maoist concentration camp
during the cultural
revolution and she stepped inadvertently
one day on a maoist armband that had
slipped off
the sleeve of an adjacent worker and for
that transgression was given
seven years of hard labor this is the
real
front lines of anthropology my friend
martin
hildebrand to whom i dedicate my most
recent book
martine a young student of anthropology
paddles down the pita parana
after he graduates in the 1960s he come
upon the hut
where he finds an old man still paying
off
the cost of a treadle sewing machines 50
years after it was bartered
to him by a rubber baron he immediately
stops establishes a rubber company that
will give the indigenous people fair and
just
prices for their product he studies the
mukul language he becomes one as a
tanimoko
and then he does his phd and then he
becomes head of indian affairs and in
1985
the president of colombia vigilia
barclay says to martin martin do
something for the indians and in five
incredible years
martine does more than something he
secures legal land tenure
for an area of land collectively the
size of the united kingdom
for the 57 ethnicities of the northwest
amazon
land rights encoded in perpetuity in the
1991 constitution of the country and
then behind a veil of isolation
created by the conflict of modern
colombia
a whole new dream of culture is born
stephen hugh jones
who lived with the barasana and his wife
christine in 1968
who revealed their world to us a world
that we would not know
of a world in which the most profound
spiritual intuition is the idea that
plants and animals are just people
in another dimension of reality a realm
of mythology that is a land management
plan that dictates precisely how people
can live with doing no harm to the
forest
he was one of the anthropologists who
predicted the disappearance
of the barasana lamentably in 1968
and he flies back in to join us in a
film project
he walks into a longhouse sees 250 men
in full ritual regalia
celebrating the fertility of cassava
woman he can't believe his eyes and he
gets
on the satellite phone to his wife
christine back in london
and he says i can't believe it the only
thing that disappeared my love
are the [ __ ] missionaries and so what
happened
is that politics changed the land went
back and when we asked some elders
why they accepted the um the presence of
these missionaries for so long who were
doing so much harm
they said something very meaningful and
profound
why did we accept them because they
promised to make us
human and that is the essence of of
colonialism to persuade the colonized
of their own inherent inferiority
and that is a cycle the anthropologist
broke and helped to break and martine
has stood as a companion a comrade
a brother of all the peoples of
northwest amazon
so if we move to the arctic and the
legendary newt rasmussen a
son of a danish missionary a mother of
inuit blood
who moved effortlessly between the
social
and cultural realms he knew the language
from birth he ran his own dogs
at the age of nine from an outpost in
northern greenland he launched seven
research
expeditions between 1912 and 1933 that
explored the length of greenland
and on the greatest of all crossed all
of north america
20 000 miles to point barrow alaska
an expedition unparalleled since that
of lewis and clark now he didn't take
these journeys
with endurance records in mind he had no
interest in being the first to do
anything
his ambitions had nothing to do with
self
travel allowed him to enter the inuit
world through the only portal
then available to him shared experience
on the open tundra
his holy grail was not a place an object
but a state of mind
a depth of understanding that would
allow him to reveal
to the world the wonder of inuit life
stretching across
all the circumpolar expanses a common
culture of the northern ice people
speaking dialects
of the same language sharing beliefs and
myths responding
to the same adaptive imperatives only
one who had physically crossed on foot
from greenland to alaska could report as
he did that a youth in greenland would
recognize a tale
told by a grandfather on the northern
slope of alaska just as an elder
there would know the folklore of the
polar eskimo
of northwest greenland and though a
child
of the arctic an adopted son of the
inuit rasmussen never
abandoned his obligations as a scholar
the research
expedition of the fifth tula published
in 1946
fields 10 volumes 6 000 pages
20 000 artifacts this extraordinary
source that today is the
invaluable portrait of the inuit before
sustained
and corrosive contact began in the 1950s
and with his wizardly gift for languages
and his well-honed ethnographic eye
rasmussen never doubted that the true
glory of the arctic
resided not in the landscape not in this
meaningless
point called the north pole but in the
genius and the vision of the inuit
his life mission was to know the world
as they did
to understand the patterns of their
lives to enter their realms of magic
and shamanic power with knowledge as his
goal
cultural understanding the quest
rasmussen completely redefined
the promise and potential of exploration
not to mention
ethnography the point is that
anthropology
exists not to tear people apart
but to bring them together it's not
about the traditional
versus the modern it's it's about the
rights of free people everywhere
to choose the components of their lives
it's certainly not about freezing people
in time like some kind of zoological
specimen as if they're frozen in the
past it's about
asking ourselves what kind of world do
we all want to live in
how can we all find a way that all
peoples everywhere
benefit from the genius of science and
modernity
but without that engagement demanding
the death of who they are as a people
and the reason for this is clear it's
not an issue of nostalgia
romance even human rights it's about
geopolitical stability
because culture is not trivial culture
is not superficial culture is not the
songs we sing the prayers we utter the
clothes we wear
the dances we do culture ultimately
is a body of ethical and moral values
that every culture places around each
individual within that culture
to keep at bay the barbaric heart that
history sadly teaches us
lies within all human beings it is
culture that allows us to make sense out
of sensation
find order and meaning in the universe
to do as lincoln said
in his first inaugural address to seek
the better angels
always of our nature and what happens
when culture is lost when the
constraints
of morality and ethics flounder and are
torn apart what happens is what happens
all around us
just take a look around as human beings
either through volition or coercion are
torn from constraints
and the comfort of their past as they
find themselves on the lowest rung of an
economic ladder that goes nowhere
in a sea of alienation and disaffection
out of that comes
all the points of crisis around the
world
so the fight for the integrity of
culture is not a rhetorical fight
it's a real battle and we have to fight
and people will die
it's not about the twiddling of thumbs
and i want to remind everybody that
we're in this together
no one has monopoly on suffering
but the bottom line is this we still
live
in a world of conflict and when we live
in a world
where the people in gaza are being
bombarded by the day
live in a world where a million ubers
are in chinese
prison camps and concentration camps
where the forest of the penang has been
laid waste and with it
a whole way of life morally inspired
inherently right
with an extraordinary knowledge of that
force has been swept away in a single
generation
anthropology must re-take
the challenges of our time it has to
take on the
the the the mission of boaz and his
people we must be the
the activist warriors who stand up for
the integrity
of all peoples of all cultural
expressions of every point of one of the
human imagination to be found in all
parts of the world
and now's the time to do it a time when
the languages are being lost the forests
are being cut
the systems of life themselves
compromised it is only humanity
that can find its way out to a brighter
day
well thank you so much wade that was
really great and i'm happy
to uh to invite you on for some q a
welcome wade davis thanks sander
um we're we're pre-recording some of
this q a because you
you might be heading off on another
expedition is that right
yeah i just don't know where i'm going
to be on june 29th you know i mean we've
been
kind of uh hell in canada we've been
very restricted
i haven't left this little island
virtually except to go skiing a few
times
since the covid thing struck this talk
is really important to me because i
i actually um you know my mother was an
anthropologist
and um and i got into design kind of as
in a way as
as a way of kind of doing anthropology
and and um and
what was very frustrating to me is i
went i went to a university so i could
take university classes along with
design classes
and then when i took anthropology it was
all about self-reflection of the field
rather than
the work and so and so i basically just
didn't do it and it was very frustrating
and so this is
this really resonates with me and i'm
i'm wondering is there a generation of
either explorers or storytellers or
or even anthropologists grad students
that are willing to go to the field or
are you seeing that's just drying oh
absolutely but they
but but they're you know in many cases
their work is not being supported by the
by the funding agencies that are
controlled by
this orthodoxy um uh you know there's
never been
more a stronger cadre of imaginative
explorers than the millennial generation
i mean
you know part of this for me is that
when i uh
you know turned my back on academic life
it didn't mean i stopped being an
academic
every one of my books i've written 23 is
a phd
for my book on everest i bought 600
books visited 57 archives
you know made three field expeditions to
the flanks of everest and and spent
months in monasteries the point is
you continue to do the ethnographic work
it's just that you publish in
uh outlets that um that
are accessible to people and meaningful
to people look we live
we live in a time where according to a
study of derek bach
fully 98 of academic papers in the
humanities
and 75 in the social sciences are
never cited again never cited once
well that's a measure of their relevance
you know we we live in a world
where at a major university like
university of british columbia where i'm
on the faculty uh something on the order
of 70
of our successful phds do not get
academic jobs
and yet the pedagogy is still based on a
calcified 1960s model
that said that if you got a phd you
became a professor and so what have we
done
the number of phds being produced is
soaring the number of tenured positions
is dropping
and the number of sessional employees
in some cases poor men and women living
in the backs of cars
you know being paid pittances to do
coursework
for uh classes full of students whose
parents are paying
huge amounts of money and tuition uh to
support that university
we watch at universities where the the
the percentage of the budget
committed to administration is soaring
whereas that pedagogy and teaching is
declining
you see that these universities are
frankly working their way out of
relevance
and i mean you touched on this a little
bit as the you know this
this massive wild kind of human
experiment that we're in the middle of
right now
covid and i'd love to just get you you
talked in your essay but
you know what is anthropology where does
it fit into
an amazing kind of time that we are in
uh amazing in the sense it's kind of
horrible but amazing
never in history has the entire world
focused on the same problem you know a
pathogen
10 000 times smaller than a grain of
salt which not only commandeer our
biology
but attack the network of community and
con
connectivity that is for a social
species what teeth and
claws represent to the tiger you know we
we saw the world shut down
and but also in that vision we saw what
the world is i mean one of the
extraordinary things about covet is that
we saw the resilience of the earth
you know overnight the skies clearing
over kathmandu and delhi and mumbai
for the first time in a generation wild
boar in the streets
of of um of barcelona
wools and grizzlies in the floor of
yosemite the canals of
venice clear rivers and colombia running
like brook streams
you know it it i found that really
inspiring and
humbling and also it showed the impact
of
human activities on the earth of course
but you know it's it's humbling to
remember
um xander if you took the entire a
hominid presence on earth i don't just
mean
homo sapiens and going back to our
immediate progenitor homo erectus but
all the way back to
homoreforensis which is somewhere 2.3
million years ago
and you take that entire timeline and
put it on a 24-hour clock of the history
of the earth
the entire hominid presence would not
occupy a second
so in other words you know the weed will
win in
the end that's that great sierra club
book said the question is
will we leave to our descendants in
earth that we can be proud of
and i think kovid you know many things
will change
coming out of kovid i think we've
discovered
that that people can work in a digital
age at home not all peoples and
certainly
not people who have to scramble for a
living every day on the streets of
cities like medellin and
lima and mumbai but certainly a number
of us can and i think we can look back
also at the frenet frenetic travel
schedules that we
all once had as a kind of violent
hallucination
i never want to have to travel like that
again it doesn't mean i won't
travel for purpose and for for for for
meaningful experiences and i hope we all
do more of that
but that image we all have of chicago's
o'hare airport on monday afternoon
like ants in a ant nest right you know
i think some of that's got to i mean
what manager can rationalize the expense
of
flying in the executive team to san
francisco putting them up in the w hotel
and
all that kind of racket you know so i
think i think i think
or people getting flown around the world
for 45 minutes oh that's right and
that's what i used to do i'd fly off to
cleveland to the ball bearing
manufacturers associated
and now of course i mean i i've found
that this new world of zoom
it has been so liberating for me now i
don't want to under
in any way under um uh state the the
the sadness and the misery we feel for
those who have suffered not
just who have lost loved ones but the
economic dislocations i mean i
i'm lucky enough to be in a place where
i didn't have economic pressures i
i i live in a place that's beautiful and
bucolic and it was a pleasant place to
sit out the pandemic so i
i'm not trying to um say that that i
wasn't
very much a person of privilege in that
um but
at the same time i remember i woke up
one morning
and uh i edited in with that that
rolling stone piece edited another piece
i was doing for a publisher in
toronto uh participated in the sonoma
writers festival
a wonderful festival that i didn't have
to go to i could just
you know and i had 4 000 people instead
of 400 people
then i administered an exam to a kid in
singapore got it back
graded it put into the registrar at the
university looked at my watch zander it
was 11 o'clock
and i went out and planted a fruit
orchard you know i mean like
i think i think we can find ways to and
i hope i hope we'll learn from our our
our year of of quietude and i want to
come back to this thing that you
mentioned in the
in your talk this kind of nexus of where
um
where you know cultural and linguistic
loss is often a precursor to massive
environmental loss and
and i think you know there's this as you
were mentioning as we lose language
after language
um and we lose the work the indigenous
people lose the words
for the things around them that also
seems to
presage them losing the care for a lot
of the things around them and moving
away from their
their their you know ancestral areas
um and so i think this is a you know
it's rare that you have a signal where
you can get a 20-year head start
knowing that the environmental loss is
going to happen in a place that's one of
the kind of signals that we
that that this kind of information gives
us but we don't seem to be acting on it
in a very good way
people are recognizing that much of the
at least terrestrial
extent biodiversity pristine lands is
at least titularly under the control of
indigenous people and so for example my
my good friend pete seligman who created
conservation international
now is with the support of the emerson
collective he's got a new organization
neotero
which is trying to work directly with
indigenous people to
um as colleagues to empower them uh to
be
stronger and more forceful and more uh
empowered advocates of their own
homelands and that
that kind of combination of uh uh
uh environmental vision of which pete
personifies uh particularly in the
tropics
with the the support for indigenous
people was almost unimaginable
in the year for example when pete um and
russ mittermeier and uh
and you know others came together to
create ci
so i think that's all very positive and
um
you know again indigenous people uh
uh you know what it's a little bit like
the environment you know i think we're
impatient with the pace of social change
but you know
when i was a kid just getting people to
stop throwing garbage out of a car
window was an environmental victory
nobody spoke about the biosphere
now that term is part of the vernacular
of school children and by the same token
when i first went to colombia in 1974
for example and i'd say to my
my friends the parents and my friends in
particular at the the nationale
the university that i was going to live
with the arawakos
in the sierra nevada they would say to
me you know porque quiere de via con la
gente
why do you want to live with the dirty
people well there have now been five
colombian presidents whose first
act of office even before their
inauguration has been to go
to the sierra to pay homage to the mamos
who have emerged kind of of symbols of
continuity and
and hope in a country that's been torn
by the drug wars
uh so so you know
it's there's much progress to be made
but we've come
in a sense a very long way and it's an
ongoing again as i said earlier
there's not a clear victory line or an
ending line it's just a process we have
to continue to do
um the idea that nations in canada treat
nation to nation with the federal
government
would have been unimaginable in the
lifetime of my grandfather but now it's
something that not as only
not only occurs it's broadly supported
by
by the canadian people and we're proud
of it well and what we're going to
wrap up here a little bit i just wanted
to um get a sense of you know what's
what is next for you as the as the
pandemic lifts
um do you i know your your most recent
book was uh just out uh
this fall about uh river and columbia
and what's your what's your next project
well my
my my real devotion is to colombia where
i was made an honorary uh citizen by
the nobel laureate juan mandel santos
who's become a good friend
um you know the book i wrote magdalena
river of dreams is really
an attempt to write a biography of a
country through the metaphor of its
its mississippi if you will the
magdalena the river of life the river
that made possible the country
colombia is a gift of the river and
the book was conceived in a moment of
great optimism in a sense written over
five years
sparked in part i was there during the
the historic signing of the peace
agreement
and it's be and because of the success
of
other books that i've had my the book el
rio for example
which um was published in colombia in
2002 a low point in the country's
fortunes
um and it became not just a hit book but
a kind of a map of dreams for
generations of kids
who couldn't travel within their own
their own country and it was embraced by
all sides of the colombian spectrum old
and young
left and right and it was actually named
by the biblioteca nationale
as one of the first 25 of what will be
the
top 200 books in the history of the
country which was a singular kind of
honor and because of that book and
films i've done positions i've had
speeches i've given the new book
i have a a voice in colombia that is is
something that i have to use
effectively and humbly
and now my question is how to use it in
the wake of these the recent
disturbances that
um have wracked the country uh it's a
it's a
it's a very sad situation that i think
the world needs to understand i mean
let's just remember that 260 thousand
dead a hundred thousand missing seven
million
internally displaced five million forced
to flee
how would the united states feel if
canada had patterns of drug consumption
laws that did nothing to limit the trade
but
uh but but empowered the cartels such
that 85 million
americans would be forced from their
homes well that's what happened in
colombia and yet during all those
terrible years
of a war that not would not have lasted
a day without the cocaine money
uh last year of war incidentally the
farc made 600 million dollars
from kidnapping extortion and drug
trafficking give me the
boy scouts of san francisco of marin
county and 600 million dollars i can
create havoc in northern california and
and during all those years columbia
maintained civil society democracy
greened its cities
uh sought restitution with indigenous
people as i've mentioned
created millions of acres of national
parks and paved the way for a
cultural economic renaissance as two
generations of kids
forced to flee are coming home with
skill sets and everywhere but here's
where things went wrong santos
negotiated the peace agreement
the peace agreement had clauses that
would cost 45 billion dollars
mostly about social development
infrastructure development
then into office came duque a protege of
alvaro uribe
who ran against the agreement and if he
didn't actively dismantle it he
certainly did little to
implement it and he didn't have the
gravitas himself that
santos who just electrified the world by
winning the peace prize
would have had say he had had a few
extra years in office and because of
that
in the void created by the retreat of
the farc
and the failure of the federal state to
enter entered into that area
dissidents cartels remember we've
continued you know until we do the
cleansing stroke of legalization cocaine
will be the curse of
colombia the rivers of blood will still
flow because of cocaine
and then and then on top of everything
uh faced with the expenses of
implementing the accord the price of oil
collapsed
colombia's main source of foreign
revenue and then colombia did something
that hasn't gotten credit for it
uh the biggest humanitarian crisis in
the history of the americas
had two million venezuelans come into
colombia and they weren't rejected at
the border as america rejects people
from central america
they were welcomed housed fed schooled
given health care and given permission
to work
and then comes kovid the economic
collapse
the social collapse poverty rates
increase after having gone down for
years
and there and then comes together kind
of a perfect storm
uh you know an ill-conceived uh
tax proposed that's going to that people
just want to hear about
in their time of economic need and
misery
uh various students
students with their grievances
indigenous people with their grievances
you know and again it's like black lives
matter it explodes
for uh in the streets it doesn't
necessarily mean that america
should be measured exclusively by what
happened in the summer of black lives
matter
for all that we need to recall and
acknowledge that wonderful phrase
um but but but so what's happening now
is sort of
this perfect storm and then it's been
accentuated by some police brutality
and um 40 or 50 at least people have
been shot unnecessarily mostly young
kids and again
what we forget is that the police part
of the department of defense
they're all coming out of a 50-year
conflict where escobar
in the very beginning made murder and
death cheap
right so you know i'm not saying that
the police
should be uh should be forgiven on the
contrary
but but you know you're you're talking
about security forces that have been
living through
all their lives a world of violence of
a three-sided war that saw 260 000
people killed
all because of north american and
european consumption of cocaine i might
add
and so so it's just broken like a storm
uh and and and you know
it's not going to put colombia back to
where it was
peace will never disappear the people
are too hungry for it and there is a
middle way in colombia
uh and and that middle way is what i
represent
and it's a place that i want to speak
from and so my biggest effort in the
next months will be
doing everything i can for colombia in
the peace process
well thank you so much for this talk and
thank you so much for joining us
and um can't wait to hear how it goes in
the coming months
in columbia i hope you're able to get
back soon thanks very much sandra
and i want to thank you our audience
with long now we look forward to having
you at our future talks thank you